Я грав професійно в футбол,
за команду «Скала» (Стрий).
Отримав серйозну травму.
Мені зробили операцію
й сказали, що не можна грати в футбол.
Думав чим зайнятись...
Ми почали 3 роки тому.
Чоловік зі Стрия мав три розвалені ферми.
Ми їх реконструювали:
збудували дахи, встановили вікна.
Як тільки завезли перших двісті кіз,
одразу почали дзвонити магазини,
домовлятись за купівлю сирів.
В нас кози 3 місяці були.
А [замовники] казали: «Нам байдуже,
що ви будете робити – ми будемо у вас купувати».
Ми зрозуміли, що є величезний попит.
І вирішили зробити проєкт не локальний,
на Стрийський район, а на всю Україну.
Коли ми зрозуміли масштаби, тоді зібрали всю сім'ю
і вирішили, що будемо всі разом цим займатися.
Ми сказали, що 10 років вся сім'я
займатиметься цим проєктом.
Моя сестра відповідає за HR-відділ
(кадровий відділ).
Я займаюсь виробництвом.
Моя дружина займається магазином,
екскурсіями й дегустаціями.
Чоловік сестри займається фермерством:
козяча й коров'ячі ферми, а також агро-сектор.
А тато з мамою контролюють нас:
передають нам досвід,
кажуть, щоб ми не робили помилки,
які вони зробили в молодості.
У нас тільки одна людина працює за професією –
це моя дружина — в туризмознавстві.
Ми відбирали людей за особистими якостями:
чистота, охайність, пунктуальність.
Сировар має бути дуже чіткою людиною.
Бо є такий технолог: найкрутіший, все знає,
але може тебе обманути, не хоче тебе слухати
й нічого не хоче робити.
А ми взяли людей, які хочуть навчатися,
хочуть рости і які зараз дуже круто варять сир.
Це наші найперші кози,
яких ми привезли з Франції. От Бембі.
Що ти?
Вона приїхала найменшою і її всі ображали.
Бачите, в неї рогів нема.
Коли вона приїхала всі її ображали,
не підпускали до корму.
Тому я завжди нишком додавав їй корму.
І вона так потроху виросла.
А тепер вона завжди канючить їжу.
Це все є французька альпійська порода.
Чому альпійська? Бо дає жирніше молоко.
Воно краще для виготовлення сиру,
тоді більший вихід сиру з молока.
Їздили чотири рази в Нідерланди
навчатись фермерства і двічі були у Франції.
Все, що бачили, брали з кожної ферми
найкращі варіанти і все це з'єднували.
Це ми купили доїльне обладнання.
Кози забігають туди в накопичувач,
там поміщається 400 кіз.
Закриваються ворота.
Після доїння в кози ще 10 хвилин
відкриті молочні канали.
І коли вона вертається додому,
може потрапити якась бактерія [в молочний канал].
[Може трапитись] щось не те,
що ми хочемо, з вим'ям.
І тому ми закриваємо канал йодом.
Через 10 хвилин молочний канал безпечно закривається,
а коза почувається щасливою.
Молоко ми охолоджуємо
до температури 3-4 градуси.
Це найкраща температура,
при якій не розвиваються бактерії.
Після того як молоко охолодилось,
ми чекаємо три години.
Після того приїжджає наш молоковоз,
забирає молоко і відвозить його на завод.
Біля Амстердаму був завод класний.
Були вікна відкриті, весь процес відкритий.
Ми позичили ідею, щоб люди бачили весь процес:
як в нас кози дояться, як вони живуть,
як ми виготовляємо сир
і як відбувається весь процес.
Визріває сир у нас тут мінімум три місяці.
Першого місяця ми перевертаємо його кожен день.
Щоб він був однаковий і рівний з обох сторін.
Тоді він буде гарної форми й красиво виглядатиме.
Потім вже раз в тиждень,
а далі в залежності від потреби.
І протираємо голови сиру оцтом,
один раз в два тижні.
Якщо якась пліснява, можливо,
осідає на сирі – то ми протираємо і захищаємо,
щоб з ним все було добре.
Сир із коров'ячої гауди
ми робимо з різними добавками.
Наприклад, шотландське віскі додаємо.
Італійський трюфель, чилі, пажитник, горіх...
І після того сир йде на продаж.
Коли ми будували завод — ідеально як є?
Спершу збудував завод –
все поставив, мишоловки є, все є.
Все там стоїть, все правильно –
тоді можна запускати виробництво.
Треба завжди робити, набивати руку.
Навіть якщо будемо робити сир –
будемо самі його з'їдати.
І це дуже нам допомогло –
зекономило десь 10 років.
Тобто ми рухаємось.